[Musica]
dieci anni fa mi sono tatuata cat
gatta sul braccio perché gatti hanno
nove vite e io sto vivendo l'ultima ho
sempre detto con tanto orgoglio per
nascondere un grande disagio
quasi a voler celebrare la fortuna di
essere ancora viva
rispetto al trauma di essere stata così
tante volte quasi morta
sono quasi morta la prima volta che ho
bevuto avevo 14 anni ed un ragazzo e mi
fece bere una bottiglia intera di
limoncello e poi iniziò a toccarmi dove
nessuno mai mi aveva toccato ignorando e
meno
sono quasi morta qualche anno dopo ad
una festa quando il ragazzo che mi
piaceva
approfittando del fatto che fossi poco
lucida mi prese per mano importante una
stanza dove eravamo soli che mi violentò
sono quasi morta entrambe le volte che
ho perso i bambini che portava in grembo
sono quasi morta poi anni dopo quando
sono andata a vivere in california e la
mia primogenita ha deciso di vivere con
il papa
sono quasi morta la prima volta che il
mio matrimonio che il mio primo
matrimonio non ha funzionato e sono
morta ancora di più quando anche il
secondo è finito
schiacciata non solo dal fallimento
personale ma anche dal giudizio altrui
sono quasi morta quando un ragazzo mi
disse che non ero materiale da
fidanzamento perché avevo già due
bambine quasi fossi una donna da
rottamare buono a nulla e sono quasi
morta tutte le volte che ho fondato
nelle sostanze il mio dolore
uno dei miei film preferiti dice il
problema non è la caduta ma
l'atterraggio ed io da brava gatta sono
sempre caduta in piedi
come un soldatino che poi è l'altra
tatuaggio che ha sul braccio sono sempre
andata avanti imperterrita con un bel
sorriso in faccia non sbaglio resa in
faccia
fino all'anno scorso
quando per l'ennesima volta il ragazzo
con cui stavo al tempo mi disse che ero
difficile da mare
difficile da mare chissà perché tra
tutte le cose che mi sono successe
proprio essere difficile via ma da mare
ne abbia ucciso forse perché l'unica
singola cosa che ho sempre voluto
disperatamente nella vita estera amata e
non riuscendo a farlo per me stessa ho
sempre cercato negli uomini che stavano
con me il mio valore e più ero disperata
per un po di amore che ho incontrato il
disprezzo di uomini che non me lo
potevano dare
essere difficile da amare mi ha ucciso e
come se per la prima volta fossi caduta
di testa invece che in piedi e
finalità era intronata ma non avessi più
saputo come andare avanti
un giorno come per magia
sono riuscita a vedermi sotto una nuova
luce
mi sono vista da fuori come una bambina
povera sola
indifesa non amata e per la prima volta
ho provato con passione
e mi sono trovata a labbra stretta dire
anche preoccupare mi prenderò cura io di
te e così ho fatto
come una mamma giorno dopo giorno con
pazienza resilienza
nessuna amata non è stato sempre facile
certe volte ho fatto finta ma sono
sempre andata avanti ogni giorno mi sono
svegliata dicendo oggi vi amerò e piano
piano
è diventato sempre più facile amarmi
e da quando ha iniziato ad amarmi è
successa una cosa bellissima
ovvero per la prima volta in vita mia ho
sentito di avere qualcosa che potessi
dare agli altri
ho capito che non dovevo essere la
persona più bravo al mondo ad amare per
poter aiutare un'altra donna ma che
proprio a condividere la mia esperienza
la mia sofferenza la mia verità avrebbe
potuto aiutare un'altra persona perché
quella persona si sarebbe potuta sentire
meno sola
per cui
in questa società ti ci vuole sempre
vincitore a tutti i costi
in questo mondo in cui siamo abituati a
celebrare sole successi
condividiamo anche il nostro dolore
condividiamo tutte le nostre esperienze
perché facendo così diamo l'opportunità
a qualcun altro di rinascere grazie
[Applauso]